hey so we're welcome to the Friday
morning session and for the first talk
we're very happy to have shy Ben David
from Waterloo and the better Institute
and he's going to discuss uh
well some
great surviving connections
okay
so I I'm kind of an outlier in this
Workshop but I am talking about
metamatematics but I'm talking about
a meta mathematics applied to to a
machine learning and what I'm going to
talk about is some improbability and
impossibility results of a basic
problems in in machine learning
so
let me start with a
very kind of a short introduction to how
I see statistical machine learning so
the statistical machine learning the
main a major problem is the following
you have some unknown probability
distribution so this is the environment
and you see a sample from that
distribution so you see a sample the
environment generates so say you see
some
patients and you assume that they are
generated by some distribution
to the empirical data
trying to
even some
as much as possible about the sample
generating distribution
so you may want to learn
the structure of the distribution or you
want or the distribution of a
binary valued
specification so you want to learn the
classification but in general what you
want is to learn as much as possible
about distribution just based on this
sample
so
it goes to ask two questions to ask uh
what prior knowledge does the learner
have
this is my my computer
what kind of knowledge does the learner
have and the other is what does a
learner wish to deduce about this
underlying distribution
so the most ambitious
framework is you say I have no prior
knowledge
and I want to learn everything about the
distribution so I have no prior
knowledge what does it mean to learn
anything everything about the
distribution what I want to do is to get
an approximation of the distribution
without any prior knowledge so that
would be the most ambitious thing no
prior knowledge I want to learn
everything
and not surprisingly I mean that's kind
of the the schema of what we're doing
there is an annual distribution it
generates some samples and we are trying
to learn what the distribution is just
based on the sample but not surprisingly
such an ambitious task is probably
impossible and it's very easy to see why
it's impossible so just consider a
discrete finite domain a set of size n
and if you have a sample size which is
less than square root of n then we know
that it's unlikely to see any point
appears twice but if no point appears
twice then you have no clue whether this
data was generated from a uniform
distribution over the whole domain or
from a uniform distribution over some
subset that includes all of the data
points
or right now in other words if I'm if
I'm running a lottery and I want to
cheat and I collect random 10 000 draws
of the lottery and now instead of
running the lottery I'm just drawing
from my 10 000 collection
as long as I will not see nobody will
see repetitions you will not know that
I'm cheating
so this is without a prior knowledge we
cannot learn what the distribution is so
this brings us so if we want to be
samples the sample size we want to be
independent of the domain size in most
cases domain size is a very large
practical infinite Okay so
it brings us two kind of important types
of restrictions so one of them is we
assume something about the distribution
we assume that the distribution comes
from a restricted family so that's kind
of what I call a prior knowledge so
let's say we assume that the
distribution is a mixture of gaussians
then we have a chance of figuring out
what the distribution is so either we
introduce some knowledge or
we say we don't want to find out
everything about the distribution we
just have a collection of queries about
the distribution that we want to be able
to answer so these are kind of two
directions in which we can diverge
because we cannot do everything at the
same time
and I will talk about both
about both problems but in this talk I
will mainly Focus about the second
approach but I will also have something
about the say something about the first
approach
so
uh so the focus will be a
characterization of a
vulnerability what can we tell about a
distribution when we don't know
in advance we don't assume in advance
what type of distribution we have Okay
so
the the kind of model that we want to
follow is the very strong results that
we know for binary classification for
one reclassification if all you want to
know is learn the binary rule then we
know that Batman is practically solves
this problem in the 70s the VC Dimension
tells you whether a class of um
so the question is can we get similar
results for more General learning
problems okay so the outline of the talk
that I will mainly describe in
possibility results on the topic of what
can we learn about distribution without
prior assumptions
and I will show this question the answer
to this question is independent of set
theory so that's kind of a surprising
connection between logic and machine
learning and that's joint work with
Carver Roberson and um
uh I will also talk shortly about a very
recent impossibility results about the
other type with my student Oscar we
showed that if you want to know which
classes of distributions are learnable
so now we go to the other direction we
assume that you know that your
distribution comes from a certain class
can you learn the distribution if you
want to know which classes are learnable
we just showed in the last month that
there can be no Dimension that
characterizes which classes of
distribution is available and which node
but I will mainly focus on the first
result
to a large extent because this is not
published yet okay so
um
a general approach to learning is
uniform estimation of random variable so
if I have a collection of queries that I
want to know about a distribution I can
view them as random variables each
answer depends on the distribution it's
a random variable so have a collection
of random variables and the simplest
approach to learning
about the answers to these random
variables is the uniform convergence so
what does it mean you get a sample the
generated annual distribution
and you want to estimate the expectation
of every query in your collection of
queries that's called a
uniform estimation we estimate the
expectation of each of the random
variables in my collection I have a
collection of queries I want to estimate
the answer simultaneously to all of them
and this is well understood and this is
the uniform convergence and uniform
convergence is really characterized by
the VC dimension of some other
dimensions of the class of queries that
you want to ask
so but that's a kind of a very strong
goal I mean you want to ask to be able
to estimate the answers to all inquiries
and in many cases we settle for
something milder which is
what we called expectation maximization
so what expectation maximization if I
have a collection of models it's not
that I want to estimate the error of
each of these models I just want to find
one model that is close to Optimum and I
don't care about estimating the
expectation or the success or the error
of all of the levels in my collection so
that's what I call expectation
maximization so we have a collection of
real valued functions or queries or
random variables or with some domain X
you get an IID sample generated by some
unknown distribution
no assumptions about the distribution
and you want to Output some H and H that
has as high as possible expectation with
respect to p so rather than estimating
the expectation of all of them which is
characterized by the visual Dimension we
just want to find a good one and we
don't care about the rest that's
expectation maximization and this is
clearly
a kind of a it's not how the problem
it's will see me in a minute it's really
an easier problem
so
many problems in machine learning can be
cast in terms of this expectation
maximization if I want to find them a
binary classification predictor I can
say each predictor has an arrow which is
an expected error of this predictor and
I don't care about the error of all the
predictors I just want to find a
predictor with minimal error so that's
kind of expectation minimization which
is the same as expectation maximization
and the same if I want to learn
multi-class not necessarily binary or if
I want to uh find the best case Center a
clustering or whatever a kind of
clustering for a distribution I have a
distribution every K table of centers is
a model I don't care about estimating
the expected loss of each of them I just
want to find a caterpillar that gives me
a result which is close to the optimal
objective
so many problems and under the list goes
on many problems that we attack in
machine learning they can be cast as
expectation maximization so what I'm
saying is that the approach of uniform
convergence that is so common is kind of
an Overkill we need less than that
so we want to characterize this
expectation maximization when is this
possible
so that the tools that we usually use I
just list some common tools in machine
learning because we are going to discuss
connection between them so pattern
availability means that you want to have
a sample size that guarantee that you
are Epsilon close to the optimum with
probability higher than one over Delta
so it's the one minus Delta so it's
probably approximately correct noise
learnability with empirical risk
accumulation that says all you do is you
listen to the sample and you find the
model that's best for the sample and
that's the model that you output and
there is weak learnability which says
rather than being able to approximate
the Optimum to arbitrary Precision you
just fix some threshold and you say I'll
be happy if I can approximate the
Optimum to 0.3
and there is a uniform convergence which
we already mentioned and there is the
existence of sample compression schemes
that I will talk about in a minute and
there is the finance of community
Dimension at the visit dimension the
nice thing is that when we talk about
binary classification all of those are
equivalent
a class is Park learnable if and only if
it is weekly learnable if and only if
ERM will learn it if and only if you
have a compression all of those
conditions are equivalent when we talk
about binary classification
the problem becomes the more difficult
so binary classification is the easy
case the fundamental theorem of machine
learning statistical learning says that
the class is all the above equivalent
and this equivalence holds even in terms
of Intel over also a Quant
quantitatively if you know one of them
you know the numbers you can calculate
the numbers for all the rest
anyway we
already in 2010 with Amita nyali and
Sivan Sabaton China Schwartz we showed
that this equivalents break down even
when you go from binary classification
to multiple classes so assume that now
you want to classify not just into two
classes but into 10 classes or to some K
number of classes then this equivalence
already breaks down we show that there
are multi-class classes for which
empirical organization algorithm
so they look
forward so
different
but they have the same if they achieve
the same results
when you look at this something that you
bought and you pick a model that
minimizes
but what you care about is the error
over the distribution yeah so in battery
classification if two you can have two
different models that have the same
error over the sample
but they can have different levels in
the redistribution
in binary classification if you have any
model that minimizes the error over the
sample you know that it would be good
for the distribution that generalization
but when it comes to multi-class
you can have different uh models
well by exhibiting for some such cases
yeah we show the exhibiting cases I mean
we show that there are algorithms that
minimize the error over the sample but
they're very they don't generate
whereas in value classification if you
minimize the error over the subtle
logarithms we also say that the practice
and
you can get to zero training error but
you need to continue to get to
generalize right but that that's that's
what happens in digital networks already
covered by the fear of clinical
conductors and even then
in practice
but but here it's in theory you we show
that there could be different algorithms
that minimize the error over the sample
and one of them will generate very well
and the other one although it minimize
the air over the sample will fail over
the dissolution
and that was a surprising result at that
time
[Music]
okay so the column
lines from two class problems to
multi-class problem this nice
equivalence already some part of it for
a part
so how large must be the output
okay so that's a good question so the
gap between different you know M
algorithms is a factor of flow K where K
is the number of classes but you can
also consider a situation when you have
infinitely many classes so you want to
learn a real valid function
and then it can be completely complete
failure for one ERM algorithm and good
success for another
but the factor is located
no matter how big the sample is you will
still pay the reason kind of an ERM
strategy
that no matter how big the sample is you
will get Fair
so no I I mean all those questions are
really in place because this was really
a surprising result and
Okay so
when I want to to focus for completeness
I mean we were talking about Imperial at
the in emacs problem we want to have the
expectation maximization so let us be
more concrete so let us focus on the
case of subset probability maximization
so what do I mean here so H is a
collection of subset of X we have some
unknown distribution
and we want to find which subset has the
highest probability
which subset in my collection has the
highest probability or close to the
highest probability again rather than
estimating the probability of hitting
each of the subsets I just want to find
one subset that has close to maximum
probability so in this case it is
already shown it is easy to see that the
equivalence breaks down because if H is
the class of all subsets of some
infinite domain
then the set of all subsets of an
infinite domain has infinite visual
Dimension so we know by what Nick
javaneki is that we will not have
uniform convergence
but if I ask you
give me a set that has maximum
probability
you know which set it is all of x
so you don't even need any samples to
answer the maximum probability question
but you won't get your uniform
convergence so this is a very simple
example where finding the maximum
probability element in your class is
much much easier than estimating the
probability of each of them
okay so in this case uniform convergence
fails because we have Infinities as I
mentioned but emacs learnability is
Trivial because you know that the
highest probability will be to if the
whole domain is one of your subsets you
just output the whole domain
Finance Company
that's my next slide
Okay so
what happens
so we want to kind of classify
characterize when a collection of
subsets or a collection of random
variables is learnable when can you
guarantee that you will find the one
close to the one with the maximum
probability
so
and they want to have a combinatorial
computerization okay so whether I will
go now I will soon talk about finite the
collection of all Finance subsets but I
want to introduce the main tool and the
main tool is compression schemes and
compression schemes they go back to Oh
Come
saying that the shortest explanation the
best what oh this is running without my
control
so what are uh so uh one manifestation
of the okamazo is the sample compression
scheme it was introduced by littlestron
and vermouth in 86. and then
so what are compression schemes so
compression schemes we can think of it
as a game between Alice and Bob I'm
borrowing the Shafi Silvio Alice and
Bobby
a terminology so
foreign
okay so Alice knows everything she knows
our family of models and she know which
model the data came from and Bob knows
only the family of models but not which
model the data came from and then Alice
gets a sample from this uh that is this
Model D fits the sample and Bob doesn't
only knows the whole family she passes
some small
subset of the sample to Bob and Bob
needs to reconstruct a good
approximation to the model just from
this small sample so that sample
compression Alice got the whole sample
she is allowed to pass to Bob only a few
points from this sample and we hope that
he can reconstruct a good approximation
to the model that generated the data
that is sample compression schemes
and we say that the class of models has
a compression of size T if they can have
an agreement between them that will
allow Bob to always reconstruct the
answer by just getting T of the samples
that Alice got
so this example compression scheme and
the middlestone environment introduce
sample compression simple binary
classification and they show that if you
have a compression scheme then it's
learnable and
morality of exactly 30 years later so
that the other direction is also correct
every learnable class has the final
compression scheme that's the binary
classification please
okay so for binary classification
pattern ability is equivalent to a
existence of a sample compression state
so now in our problem is that we want to
do this emacs problem and the Emax
problem is different so we came up with
a notion of sample compression for the
Emax problem I don't think it's
important to read the technical details
I will demonstrate this sample
compression scheme for the simple case
of collection of subsets
so for a collection of subsets and we
showed that the existence of a
compression scheme is equivalent to an
ability for a collection of subsets so
let me explain to you what is the
compression scheme for the collection of
subsets so
the collection of subsets say we look at
all the finite subsets of some domain X
and
there is a distribution we don't know
what the distribution is we generate the
sample we want to find the subset or a
subset that has as much as possible
probability so
Alice gets the final sample and she is
allowed to pick only a small subset of
this sample to pass it to Bob and Bob
needs to find a subset ETA of S Prime
and we want to guarantee that this at of
S Prime is close to having the maximum
probabilities
and the the what so that's kind of the
game that we are playing can we have a
game in which I'm getting there is an
annual distribution of a final
substitute of some domain next I'm
getting I'm Alice I'm getting a finite
sample I'm passing to a almost a a small
sample he should be able to reconstruct
uh we want to reconstruct a sample that
is a superset of s
so because we want to have something
with maximal probability if the sample
is s if I you will work well if you can
reconstruct a superset of politics so
let us play this game this is a kind of
a very yes this knows what the
distribution is Alice knows everything
right Alice knows that
but the problem is that Alice just go to
sample s and she can only transfer a
subset of those right a small subset of
those and it is suffice it will suffice
for learning we should suffice if both
can reconstruct a superset of this
okay so let's you're running ahead of me
one time one slide ahead
so let us see when this game is doable
and when
so
if x is a
effects depends on the cardinality of
this if x is finite it's trivial
because if x is is finite then Bob has
to answer with a final subset of x
so Bob can also answer can only answer
with X or of X it sure will be a cover
of the sample
what happens if x is countable
if x is countable so say the natural
numbers so Alice gets knows the
distribution of the natural numbers she
gets a finite sample she has to pass to
Bob only few of them and he needs to
come up with a set that covers the
finite sample
so what will you do with a countable
domain
that's right take the maximum element
and Bob will say here is the initial
segment it's a finite set and it covers
the sample because it was the maximum
element of the sample so it's very easy
if it's countable what happens if
what happens if x is uncountable
then it becomes interesting so now with
our game is as follows I mean our domain
says the real numbers
uh Alice gets a finite set of V numbers
she has to pass to Bob only few of them
and Bob has to recover a subset of real
numbers that is a superset of the
original s
how can they do it
so for three numbers it becomes really
challenging
but
all possible extensions yeah but if you
take an initial segment of a railroad
during the wheels it's not going to be a
final set
Bob has to Output Define and set
sure I could take a well ordering of the
wheels repeat the the idea of a maximum
element Bob will give the initial
segment but it's an infinite set Bob has
to come up with a finite set
so it becomes difficult so
the main combinatorial result that we
showed is that if you have finite subset
of x there is a compression scheme of
size K if and only if x is less than
alif k
so this is a kind of a new
characterization of the Cardinals RFK
I mean it is it's I mean I'm enjoying it
even when I'm telling it for the
hundredths time
so what is just let me remind you what
are the alif case so the Alps are the
infinite Cardinals well ordered so alef
null is the cardinality of the natural
numbers and each alif M plus one is the
first Cardinal that's larger than
elephant and the Canto theorem tells us
that the real numbers are greater than
RF zero but the poor coin famous results
of the continuous tells you that you
cannot prove what exactly is the
cardinality of the real number this is
independent of zfc so it could be any of
the rfks it could also be above all the
rfks
we cannot even prove whether it's one of
the early kfks or it's above
but now we can go back to our problem
we said in the previous slide
we said that
previously yes we said that you have a
finite compression scheme of size K if
and only if your domain is less than
alif k
so now I'm playing the game over the
wheels and the claim I can win the game
over the reels if and only if the
cardinality of the wheels is one of the
alif case which is independent of set
theory
so we show that the compression game is
independent of set the area we can do it
or not but the compression game is
equivalent to emacs learnability
so we get the T-Max liabilities
independent of set theory so let me say
something about
um
about the proof so where am I going
backwards forward
okay
okay so
just to say something about the proof of
this nice characterization of the rfks
if I want to show that if x is less than
lfk then you haven't won the conversion
of size case we can do it by induction
of K so think of it as
say that the reals are alif one how do I
get a compression scheme so I take a
real ordering of the reels such that any
initial segment is countable
now Alice gets his sample she gives me
the element which is maximum in the
sample but of course I cannot give Bob
the initial segment because it's
countable
but then I look at the rest of the
sample now it's countable I can map it
to the natural numbers
and there is a maximal element in the
mapping to the natural numbers
so Alice can give just two points one of
them tells you which countable ordinal
covers all of the sample and the second
element that Alice gives tells you once
you know it's a countable ordinal you
can map it to the natural numbers take
the maximum of the natural numbers it
will give you a finite set
so if the cardinality of the real is and
if one you can do compression of size
two and similarly you can do compression
of size
a k is the cardinality of the radius is
alif K minus one
and we'll can also show the other
direction well
we can also show oh I see what my
problem is each time I'm turning it like
this
forward and backwards switch
okay so we can also show that the other
direction that if you have a compression
scheme of size k then the cardinality
cannot exceed
um
a k minus one okay so we get this result
now we don't need anything so smart as
Ramsay but we need
playing some games yeah
okay so because Ramsay would have given
us bigger gaps than just one
okay so um
for the immature ability we can show
that the following is equivalent so we
said in maximum abilities find just the
model which is close to the best
and for image celebrity we can show that
pack Leon ability I mean you will you
want this probability one minus Delta to
find something which is Epsilon good is
equivalent to weaker and ability that is
if you can give me something which is
0.3 good then you will be able to give
me something which is arbitrarily good
and this is equivalent to this monotone
existence of this monotone compression
scheme
and
so if we go to over the equivalence that
we had before now we just have the
equivalence of the blue guys
and we were left with the question of
can we find a dimension that will
characterize IMAX energy we already know
that IMAX and ability of the set of four
final subsets of the Winds is
independent of set theory independent of
ceteria whether it's learnable or not
but we still can ask can I find the
dimension with characterized
and uh now we you use a something more
sophisticated than set theory in order
to show that it can be no Dimension but
in order to show that there can be no
Dimension I need to Define what I mean
by a combinatorial dimension so the
definition that we took here
okay we also have a quantitative version
which I don't think matters so much well
well we
um
I'm not sure if I'm going backwards of
okay
okay can we find a couple of
conversation so the question is what do
I mean by characterization so a
computerization I mean that we have a
first order formula that quantifies over
members of X and of the members of H if
you recall what is the Visa Dimension
this Dimension says there exist this
Dimension is D if there exist D points
such that every 0 1 labeling of these
points is realizable by one of the H's
in h so we have the exist X1 to XD in X
and there exists H1 to H2 to the D in h
such that they realize every combination
so we say Define a dimension by having a
first order formula that quantifies over
X and quantifies over h
and you want that the dimension will be
such that a class is learnable if and
only if the dimension is found
so
we know that we have it for this
Dimension and many other dimensions like
fetcha during Dimension the graph
Dimension nitrogen Dimension many
dimensions have been discussed all of
the dimensions that we know for machine
learning they all fall into this pattern
of combinatorial Dimension it's the
first note the formula with
quantification of elements of the domain
and over elements of age
okay so now we show that you cannot have
such a characterization for the
learnability for the IMAX availability
so
here we used a kind of a tool from a
forcing technique so if you have a sub
model and both models both are models of
zfc when we do first thing we construct
we start with the model of zfc in which
some statement holds then we go to a sub
model of this in which the statement
fails and both of them are models of set
theory so if you if I have m0 which is
the model a sub model of
M1 and both uh satisfy NFC and both
share the same domain and the same class
then any finite characterization the
truth value of any such formula is the
same in M1 and in m0 if I have a formula
that only quantifies over Elements which
are common to both models first of the
formula it will be the same value in in
both models
so what it means is that we if we have a
finite characterization
then when we go between different models
of zfc I ask you is H learnable
the answer in one model of zfc will be
the same as the answer is the other
model of fzfc because the
characterization is limited enough to
not change between the models
so
uh jump to the call away anyway so we
can construct two models of set theory
in which the reals are the same in which
finite subsets of the reals are also the
same
but in one of them the cardinality of
the reels is above Aleppo Omega so e-max
fails in the other one the cardinality
of the wheels is one of the alif case so
emac succeeds so I have two models of
zfc in which every carboxylization will
give me the same answer
but in one of them this class is
learnable and the other is not learnable
therefore I cannot I prove that I cannot
have a notion of Dimension that
characterizes this IMAX availability
Okay so
that's the conclusion there could be no
finite character notion of Dimension
that characterizes
emotional ability
and it's worthwhile thinking I still
want to talk about the other direction
as well but let me just uh have a
comment here it's very as well thinking
where is this Independence coming from
because we're talking about weak
learnability I just want to learn up to
approximation point three
and I have finite samples where is this
Independence sneaking in and the reason
is that when machine learning
statistical machine learning is defined
it's defined in terms of learning
functions not of learning algorithms
when we talk about a learner you want a
function from samples to models but
there is no requirement that this
function is computable if this function
well computable then every program will
be a finite element and there will not
be this type of Independence so it
brings about a point that was not really
paid nobody paid attention to before
that there is a gap here in our
definition of vulnerability in the nice
characterization
because we didn't require that they
learn as much we must be computable so
if we learn as computable we will not
get such an independence and we indeed
we embarked on this direction of what
happens to classical machine learning
even binary classification when you
require that the Learners much must be
computable must be programmed so this is
a series of works with the students of
mine with we defined learnability in
terms of requiring computable of the
learner and we showed that the physical
authorization of binary valued functions
fails so already in binary valued
functions the characterization by
buttons collapses if you require the
Learners to be a computable and also in
recent work with another student Nikki
we showed that the characterization of
online learning
collapses if you want the Learners to be
computable
so it's kind of the the and the
undecidability came from the fact that
we did not require any definition that
Learners are computable so let me finish
with the result in the other direction
so as I said there were two directions
one of them we restrict the collection
of distributions and ask if you know the
collection of distribution can you tell
me which one is the model the other one
you don't respect you do distribution
free but you only ask certain questions
so that was about the second problem
this independence with the first problem
so
the question of characterizing which
families of probability distributions
are learnable it's been open for 30
years we just showed with another
student of my translation that there
could be no notion of Dimension that
characterizes the inability of finite
domain distributions
so if I if you ask the following
question I mean in the previous work for
example we showed sample compression
sample schemes that for learning mixture
of those so we know that if you know the
distribution is a mixture of gaussian I
give you a sample you can approximate it
well but there was still the open
questions mixture of gaussians work well
which distributions which help families
of distribution will not work can we
find the dimension for this and we show
that there can be no dimension for this
and the the
technique is completely different let me
just do some just explain it on the boat
so what do I mean no Dimension so if if
we talk we talk about dimension in
Sample complexity and learning
we talk usually about this function
which is MH
of Epsilon Delta which means number of
sample size
required
to
Epsilon data level
to get Precision Epsilon with confidence
at least one minus Delta so this is the
sample complexity function and if we
have a dimension we know that for every
h m h of Epsilon Delta is actually a
function of the dimension of H and
Epsilon and Delta all that you need to
know about the class is the VC Dimension
if you know the visit Dimension you know
the sample complexity as a function of
Epsilon D so a dimension in some way it
captures all the relevant information
from your class age
so what we showed is that if you the
classes it's classes of distribution or
finite distributions there are too many
behaviors to be captured by just a
natural number
there are too many behaviors to even be
captured by just the women
so there can be no Dimension that once
you know the dimension of the class you
will know what is the learning rate for
that class
just because there are too many
behaviors and you cannot
compress them into just a single number
okay so these are my impossibility
results for today thank you
[Applause]
okay questions
let me start actually I have two
questions
being learned so they still hold for
this side
uniforms
I mean this is kind of the last few
weeks that we got Instagram okay and the
other question is
so you convinced me that come into our
learning theory has nothing to say about
their ability
right that's what you showed if you
cannot stand it but in the real world
missionary making a big strike so is
this Theory actually relevant for
anything so I think that I tried to in
some way answer it by saying in real
world machine learning programs the
Learners are programs and once you have
the Learners programs you don't have
this impact
but the downside is that once you have
mentioned them as programs then also the
nice characterization that we all know
except as as the truth from God
breaks down
so we get the advantage Independence
that theory but we are really just
making First Steps in understanding
characterization under computable
who believes which is the realistic
situation
yes if the Learners are algorithms then
X is supposedly accountable
right so so in order to talk about
algorithms you have to encode X and uh
yeah so you have to code X and you have
to encode if it is countable that there
is no Independence no I have the same if
you require the algorithms to be
learnable to be computable then there is
no Independence that's what I'm saying
yeah but a stronger statement is that it
could require X to be countable then
there is no Independence if you require
X to be countable then
it's not I mean this Independence result
will not work for countable X but there
could be age could still be
uncomfortable and the the class of all
Learners could be
uncountable so it's not obvious that for
countable X you will not be Independence
there are actually several Community
models of Hardware computers that can be
done
can you show again this main
characterization with like the number of
samples in the cardinality
oh yeah
foreign
case in terms of
a finite gain
with pilot outcome
yes so for this last result
um
because you know each distribution is is
even a finite support
but the collection of we talk about the
classroom distribution
so you have many classes of this
solution
every class of distribution is counted
but we're talking about characterizing
whether a classic distribution is
notable no so we want this function you
want this function D to be a function
from all classes of distributions
so yeah it is the negative result
already holds for distributions of a
finite subset of natural numbers
okay
okay so let's think try again
[Applause]
we are doing at 11 A.M for two more
talks
foreign